alors vu que vous êtes blessé robert
pirès vous comprendrez qu'on vous fasse
une interview dernier coup bien les
coups de tête je suis pas méchant donc
est-ce que pas d'en mettre
ouais dernier coup de coeur dernier coup
de coeur
le dernier cadeau que j'ai pu offrir à
ma femme pour son anniversaire
c'est quoi c'est un c'est un collier en
forme de coeur un diamant
un diamant j'aurais dû épouser un
footballeur matchs l'an dernier coup de
folie il montre cher oui oui quand même
acquis pour moi je passais de merde
j'en écoute pub
bachand point elle est fin du mois fin
du mois ne disposions que tu prends un
shampooing pour y gagner coup de fil
c'était un ami pour savoir où j'allais
manger ce soir
ouais vous appelait encore hey les mecs
là maintenant ouais
jean-noël en relation et sylvain wiltord
qu'est ce qui dit sylvain non ça va ils
vont bien il faut pas s'en inquiéter un
joueur tout le monde s'inquiète
commandement est trop inquiet là
commence à paniquer un peu donc qu'il
faut il faut attendre simplement pas
temps de la finale tu crois non non
dernier coup de rouge
je vois pas larry coup de bluff là
maintenant y voit là maintenant
dernier coup de bol la coupe dernier
coup de blues français légal d'ouverture
de la coupe du monde
ouais difficile de se dé quoi le score
1-0 pour le sénégal
diouf je n'ai pas su gagner un dernier
coup de rein hier soir là les amis et
tout ça non
la journée
je n'y crois pas